about discovering abstract topics that
occur in a collection of documents
and to illustrate that uh
we see in this wikipedia page you have
all a bunch of text and we want to be
able to transform this to the most
important words in that text
so in this example we see topic document
words text model and this process from
the wikipedia
text
so
basically i wanted to how can we build
this type of functionality in python
where the input is just a document and
then the output is just the topics
associated with that
so there's a library called gensim which
is a topic modeling uh library that has
lots of different cool uh abilities and
apis and
just ways to interact with text but to
actually do that simple step of creating
a topic model and outputting those
awards consist of going through 18 20
different steps to kind of just build a
pipeline to do that
but not very really beginner friendly a
lot of steps involved and it's really
not an easy process
so one of my guiding principles how can
we invent and simplify the process of
topic modeling so it's more accessible
to developers like
so i designed this open source uh
platform called topic blob which is
basically a simple api that takes in
text and you get topics out of it
there's model off another popular
library called text blog which you just
take text and it gives you a sentiment
analysis so similar type of thinking
here you have blah text as the input and
then you get
topic text as the output
and
here's an example of the text a lot of
random text paragraphs you may not make
an array of those text paragraphs topic
blob you just pass in the documents how
many topics and words and then it does a
bunch of analysis and then you get each
of the topics displayed right right then
and there this is a simple uh
api that just
encapsulates that entire process gensim
is doing behind the scenes
and i actually
open source built this with the
community during oktoberfest of 2020.
so
about eight different uh community
members were able to come in and take
issues uh
close these issues work on them and it
was great just having other
individuals come in and build the
application besides me
but when you're building a
community-based application you need to
have
well-scoped issues so people can easily
jump in and get get in and start
building one of the biggest periods of
the entries i see in open source
projects there's no really clear path on
how to start and what what i can do as
an individual contributor or this
hacktoberfest there are people from all
over the world participating and i don't
know when there's no really a sense of
like what they've done before so just
setting up them up for success is a
really important thing for getting
community involvement so
i always start what the task is why do
you want to do the task and then how
somebody can get started and that
definition of done by providing that
template it really allowed those
individuals to easily contribute to the
project
then uh so a quick little demo uh one of
the things was actually make a us a
streamer application with a topic blog
and the idea is basically we have a
bunch of wikipedia pages
uh we can see all the actual text topics
that are extracted from each of those
you can find similar pages so topic blog
does other text analysis tasks that says
finding similar pages based on the
topics uh doing ranked search
so i did python here did a rank search
find
find things that have that python but
python's the only one and what examples
i put
search for specific topics so if i
search meta facebook company comes up
so really this gives you an opportunity
to do a lot of text processing tasks
around topic modeling and
is open source
it's a github you can post it afterwards
and you can install it with pip install
topic blob so it's
it's really cool to build this with the
community so i had eight different
contributors build this
and this i really never saw anything
else that really encapsulated the topic
modeling uh api using gensim was great
but there's so many steps involved to
doing it it wasn't very easy and user
friendly so this was really the
motivation to have to embed and simplify
that process of topic modeling and have
a nice api that allows anybody to use
that
um that's all my talk thank you
thank you so much banjo for the talk and
i guess we can have time for a question
uh maybe in the chat if anyone has any
but uh otherwise
if not
we can switch gears to the second talk
with thomas
and as you get ready thomas just uh
hello do you hear me
yeah
okay great and are you seeing my screen
yes
okay great can i get started
yes
okay hello everybody it's a pleasure to
be here
giving this lighting talk for all of you
i'm tomas capreto i am from argentina
and today i'm going to talk about bambi
which is a new library for basin
modeling in python
so let's get started by reviewing the
outline of this talk
so i'm going to describe what is bambi
and the main features around bambi
i'm going to give you some examples
where i'm using bambi to do base and
modeling
then we have some short time for
conclusions
and i'd like to tell you how you can get
involved with the project
so
bambi stands for base and model building
interface
and it is an interface because it is
built on top of
other libraries like pimc and rvs so
every time you create a model in bambi
bambi under the hood is creating a model
in pmc
and we use rvs because of the data
starters data structures that it
provides
and many plotting functions to analyze
prior and posterior distributions for
example
and now let's review some of the main
features in bambi
bambi supports generalized linear mixed
models
these models are also known as
multi-level models or hierarchical
models especially in the bayesian
literature
bambi has a short and simple model
specification syntax
this
model formulation with a model formula
is inspired on the r programming
language and the model formulas that you
can use there and the result is that you
can
write your models with
less code which results in
you know save time
bambi supports both numerical and
categorical predictors and it doesn't
ask the users
to perform any complicated data
preparation steps
and these steps are usually associated
with errors so it saves you debugging
time
bambi doesn't doesn't enforce you to use
to explicitly pass
your
your prior distributions so this is good
for iterative model building
but bambi also allows you to pass your
priors when you have the model that you
want to use and it's recommended that
you once you have that model you use
your priors
and finally if you are familiar with how
pimc works and you fight and you feel
comfortable working with imc
bambi still gives you access to the
underlying pmc model
so
let's get started with a for example in
this example we are interested in
estimating the
about probability we are going to use
some survey data coming from the
american national
election studies and
this data can be loaded with bambi very
easily with the load data function
and we can see we have three columns
both which is our variable of interest
the response variable
the age of the respondent and the part
identification of the respondent oh this
was data collected before the 2016
election
so
and we are going to build a model to
estimate the probability of voting for
clinton
so
let's go to the next line
and something very important is that
all the models in bambi are created with
a modal class
and it has two mandatory arguments the
model formula
that we can see here
under that and the data which is a
pandas data frame that bambi is going to
use to look for the variables that we
are passing in the model formula
here we are using a third optional
argument to tell bambi that we are
analyzing a binary variable
and bam is going to interpret this as a
variable as a binary variable because we
are here we are saying okay my response
is both but i want you to model the
probability that both is equal to
clinton
this means that we are not using an
intercept in the model
this means that we are using the part
identification as the predictor and this
means that we are using the interaction
between the part identification and the
age
when we print the bambi model we have
some important information
like for example the prior distributions
which is something that we didn't
specify when creating the model and so
here we can see for example that
bambi has chosen
uh
normal distributions centered at zero
which is a pretty common choice
and it has estimated
sorry i hear something
oh okay
it's fine yes and it has estimated the
standard deviation uh using
a method that
we have implemented for for this purpose
then once we specify the model it's time
to start the the fitting process
and in bambi it's as easy as saying
model.fate
and under the hood it is calling the
the sampler from ymc
it's giving us some good information
confirming that we are modeling the
probability that we want to model
and all the other messages are thanks to
the pi mc sampler
which tells for example that's that this
fitting process
took 11 seconds
the result of this fitting process
is an object of class inference data
that we are going to use to analyze the
posterior results
so
we specified the model we fitted the
model
now for example we
let's suppose we have
data about other subjects subjects that
we didn't use
in the training stage what but we want
to know
what's their probability of voting for
clinton
so
let's say we have these two observations
they
are both from the independent party and
they are aged 20 and 60.
so all we need to
obtain these basin predictions
is to use the predict method
we pass the inference data object that
the fitting process returned and we pass
the new data frame
this is going to update this inference
data object and we can easily create a
chart like this one
which for example tells that the
probability of voting for clinton is
higher for
for the youngest person
but however
we have more certainty about this
estimation because the distribution is
wider
we have distributions because we are
using base and inference so these are
posterior distributions
and if you have a little more time and
more creativity you can create
this which is more
more informative so instead of having
only two observations you can create a
bunch of observations and create a plot
use the same predict method and create a
plot like this one to analyze the
association between age and probability
of voting for clinton for the different
uh party identifications
and
this is one of the good things about
bayesian inference because we not
only see
the
estimations like for example that
democrats always have high probability
of voting for clinton but we also have
uh
an idea of the uncertainty about the
estimations
so we are more certain about these
estimations that
for example these other estimations that
are highly variable
and so
and as i said
bambi is an interface to bmc and it
writes pimc code under the hood and so
this is how the prime c code for the
same model looks like as you can see
this is much more expressive
it's it may be
more clear clearer from for some people
but it's also much more cold
and so
you can make more mistakes here
then we have another example
that i'm not going to cover in
such a depth detail
so this example is about
a psychological study
where people were
deprived from from sleep
and they wanted to study reaction times
uh after several days of sleep
deprivation
so this is a plot of of the data we have
one panel for each subject subject we
have the days here and the reaction
times here
we are seeing
that
the reaction times increase as people
are more depleted from sleep
and so we are going to estimate a linear
model here but this linear model is
going to be a hierarchical model because
we also we want to include
an intercept and slope common to all the
subjects but we also want to model the
deviations of each subject from this
global pattern so we are going to
include
intercepts and slope specific to the
subjects
doing this in bambi is as easy as adding
this type of term
this is just saying that we want a daisy
slope for each subject and implicitly it
is saying that we also want an intercept
and
you can see that
this summary is much longer now because
we have many more terms
and again
fit in the model is about using the feed
method
so
we can
to to have an idea of
if
subjects differ
we can see the posteriors for the
subject specific intercepts and the
posteriors for the subject specific
slopes
and so the first thing that we note
comparing the intercepts is that
subjects differ
in their init their initial reaction
times
some of them are below the mean some of
them are above the mean
but they also differ in how much they
are affected by
the sleep deprivation some of them are
more effective so their slope is larger
and some of them are less effective so
the slope is not that large
and here we can
from that information the posterior uh
using some rvs and mathematical we can
obtain a plot like this where we have
the estimated linear regression for each
subject and the bands indicate a
credibility interval a base and
credibility interval
and this
is the pimc version of the same model
again it's a much longer piece of code
it's much more expressive it's clear
about what's going on if you know what
you're doing
but we have i don't know 20 lines of
code when we have here
this line of code
so
conclusions
bambi provides a simple syntax
since it's simple and shorter
it is less error prone
it is still flexible
you can
use your own priors you can create your
own family of models i haven't covered
that here but feel free to have a look
at the documentation
it is not as flexible as 5mc of course
it is going to be familiar to you if you
have experience with r because of the
formula of the model formula
and it reduces more importantly it
reduces the cognitive load
so you don't have to think
that much about how to ride your model
you can take that time to think about
your problem
and finally i want to tell you how you
can get involved with this project
so bambi is hosted and developed on
github
if you are interested about the library
please
uh contribute with anything you want we
have a documentation webpage
and you can reach out any of the core
developers on twitter if you use twitter
you can find oswaldo martin
and you can find me on twitter and we
are very open to suggestions ideas
questions
or anything that the community has to
say about the project
and
thank you very much thomas thank you
awesome meme uh
and uh just before we go to the next
talk we have a question from brian
are there any plans to provide operator
overloads so that users don't have to
specify models using strings
and i'd like to ask you to answer it in
one minute or less that's my challenge
to you so
but
you should know how to
um
no so
so in r you don't use a string because
of how r evaluates the arguments of
functions
so you can pass something that doesn't
look like as a string because it uses
a
lazy evaluation
but in python
you are forced to use a string but if
your question doesn't go it's not about
that point
so
we are going to keep using this string
because it was what it makes difference
payments here from bandy
yes yes
thank you so much thomas i think you
answered the question perfectly
okay and before we move to zachary i was
challenged by the
the the conference chair to throw in
some jokes
i mean i have deep learning jokes but i
cannot explain it so um
i guess we can move to the next talk
with zachary
about automatic pattern based data
catalogs
uh exactly are you here with us or i am
yep can you hear me yeah
wonderful
hello everyone uh thanks for coming uh
these lightning talks my name is zachary
blackwood and i am a
on the data science infrastructure team
at dtn
uh we're a global leader in agriculture
and weather and energy
and i want to talk to you about a
problem that we had on the with the data
science team in terms of cataloging our
data and how we solved that through an
existing library and also through adding
on to it with with a new library called
intake pattern catalog or affectionately
shortened to pattern cat
uh hence hence our icon
um so
really the reason behind all this is
we face this problem again and again on
the data science team um that we have a
lot of data uh we're
we're a data we're a very much a data
driven company got access to a lot of
data it's just a matter of where it is
how do you get it um and every time a
new project came along or there was a
there was a quarterly hackathon and we
had some great idea
um
it was
it was typically about you know 80 of
the time was spent finding the data
figuring how to access it figuring out
what we need to load it
uh
and so we had this
um we had this issue and one of the
things we did to solve it was to create
a
uh a data catalog for to to make our
what might be generously called a data
lake into something that's actually
uh more usable and and accessible
um
so the first part of our solution was
was finding and using this this
wonderful library called intake so
intake is a is a a tool for creating
uh
data catalogs where you write down the
catalog specification in gaml files and
then it provides
um so so with each with each entry in
your data catalog you specify where it
is
um
and also what kind of driver you need to
access it so whether it's a csv or
you're going to use you're going to load
it with some a parquet reader or it's
sql
and not only does it then give you
a a way to to see what data is there but
also gives you a a consistent python api
for accessing the data
um and this was this was really a game
changer for
uh for us for getting for getting access
to the data and for making it the the
process much much smoother
um and so the the the workflow
for
uh finding new data and getting access
is used to be something like this you
know you
well i gotta uh look in this certain
folder or
under
find look in a certain location find the
file that i'm looking for
use this specific tool to get to get the
data and then you and then do some other
filtering and cleaning and
to get the actual data that i want in
the format that i want it and this was
the this this was almost always the the
case there was always this multi-step
process that was always different
depending on where the data was and what
format it was in
uh and and once we started using intake
the steps become
call this python api
catalog.category.dataset.read where
category and data set all right and it
really is that easy and this is a huge
game changer for us it gives you access
to this this data as a as a as a data
frame or as
or as a dash data as a pandas data frame
or a dash data frame or other various
formats
um
and
this this alone was it was it was a big
game changer in terms of not only seeing
what data was there but also having
having access uh having easy access to
it without having to worry about what it
was under the hood
um
but there was a particular use case that
that wasn't entirely solved with this we
have a lot of cases where we have a lot
of data on ns3 and some on on disk
somewhere
and it would often be stored in a
structure like this where you have you
know a certain bucket a certain folder
maybe a customer name and a date and a
version
and so we had these cases where look
here's a lot of data it's really the
same kind of data maybe even have the
same
may have the same structure and
everything in the same format
but we didn't want to reference this by
creating a whole bunch of separate
entries in our yaml catalogs that wanted
to have a single entry that contained
this
that would allow us to reference an
individual one of these so there was
already functionality for if your data
was split into multiple files but these
really are separate data sets and we
wanted to be able to
create a single entry that allowed us to
access multiple of these and pull them
out as separate data frames
so that's why
we created this
thing what we call intake pattern
catalog
is
installable now with conda
it's on condo forge you can install it
with pip
and the the way of using it is is very
similar to what you would do with a
regular intake catalog
um the the differences would be that you
specify this pattern cat is the is the
name of the driver
and then you specify instead of giving a
hard
url
either a local url or something
or something on s3 for example
you give you give it with this this f
string style patterns and so you say
here the syntax or the structure of my
data is always going to be in something
bucket folder some customer name some
date with this format and some version
number
and then underneath for each individual
entry i'm going to use the parquet i'm
going to use the parquet driver
underneath the hood
and so this allowed us to to describe
uh
this whole this whole group of
files with the single entry in our
intake catalogs
and then to access an individual entry
you can here this is this this custom
for example this customer sales uh
catalog entry which is itself a catalog
it's a catalog of all the different
customer different parquet files for
example
if you list it you can see all the
different entries that are there
and then if you want to get a particular
entry you can just pass with keyword
arguments say the customer name and the
date or whatever the parameters are
in the
in the uh
pattern that you described and then
doing dot read or dot to dash or
something like that to get it in the
format that you wanted out
and so this allowed us to compactly
describe things that are a whole bunch
of files even a bunch of files that is
growing over time as we add new data and
still have a single entry
um so we're using this extensively at
dtn we're using it
both in experimental projects and also
in production
here's some of the ways that we're using
it we have a lot of things where
we have similar kinds of files but
there's a cut different customer names
in the path or we use different
different processing steps so we have a
version number in the file name or we do
a lot of with weather predictions and so
we have we'll often have weather weather
that has a date
in various various formats
and
we even use it to get to get our models
or the model data or the predictions um
that have maybe the model version in the
in the path name
and so all of these things are now
much much easier now that we have this
way of building on top of intake um
so some of the takeaways are uh that the
things that i've learned and the
teamvest has worked on this has learned
is that intake is is a really useful
tool uh if you have this situation where
you have data in lots of places and you
have don't yet have a way of creating a
data catalog highly recommend uh using
the intake library um the intake library
was built from the very beginning to be
to be pluggable so it was built uh with
instructions on creating plugins and
there's many many community creative
plugins out there now on this this
particular one even though it's a fairly
different uh
behavior and that a single entry
represents a whole a whole catalog
because of the the plugin based system i
really made it very approachable and and
doable to create and it's the whole code
base is less than less than 300 lines of
python code um and then this was
actually our our company's first uh open
source open source project and and the
experience of getting it on pi pi and
then getting automatically released on
conda forge was uh much easier than at
least i expected from my first
experience with it so uh if if that's
something you've never done it's it's
very approachable and there's lots of
there's lots of community help and
there's lots of nice nice bots that will
help with the process of auto releasing
new ones so if you have
data catalog issues highly recommend you
use uh intake uh if you wanna you want a
python api for accessing your data take
take a look and take pattern catalog if
you think it'll solve a problem that you
might have or create your own intake uh
intake plug-in if there's some use case
that you don't see there
yet
thanks a lot zach
thanks a lot zach we have a question
from mark uh he's asking uh
can you have a multiple can you have
multiple patterns per entry uh for
example to cover the case for different
date formats
uh that is not yet supported uh but no
so we we only allow a single a single
pattern uh
so you have to yeah that is that is a
limitation you would have to have a
separate a separate entry for um
for a given
uh for a given entry
right
thanks a lot zach uh do we have ryan
with my grad
yep
all right i try to think of jokes
between the talks but
my like the one i came up with wasn't
statistically significant so let's let's
move on to the next one
i i dig it i was gonna say uh my joke is
gonna my talk is gonna be a joke in and
of itself so we should be good can
everyone see my slides and hear me
hopefully yeah
all right
hey everyone i'm ryan soklasky and i
want to present to you my grad which is
a library that adds drop in automatic
differentiation to numpy
so in this lightning talk i will
describe what automatic differentiation
even is
what i mean by drop in
how mygrad pulls this off oops
and i'll compare and contrast my grad
with jax which is another numpy centric
auto differentiation library
and then i'll talk a little bit about
why i think this community should care
about migrants or why they might care
about my grad
okay so what is automatic
differentiation
if i have a number
that in my code i represent as a my grad
tensor
i can pass that to any mygrad or numpy
math function and get out
some output which will be represented by
a my grab tensor
because this is a mygrad tensor it has a
method called backward
that tells mygrad to compute all of the
derivatives of that function
with respect to the input so we get the
derivative of the function evaluated at
that specific value x naught
and this is returned as a numpy array
so a lot of you who have done machine
learning have probably encountered auto
diff automatic differentiation via
pytorch jacks tensorflow this is like a
totally essential technology that
undergirds the deep learning revolution
and gradient based learning
so let's see what like what this looks
like in actual code um i make a my grad
tensor this is just like a numpy array
i can pass that my grad tensor directly
to a numpy function and this isn't like
some special version of numpy that
migrate provides this is just vanilla
numpy numpy.sum
the return is a tensor so i can call
backward on it and that tells migrant to
compute the derivatives of f with
respect to x at that input
okay so that's just to make sure we're
all on the same page of what this would
look like to use in our code
now what do i mean by drop-in in terms
of drop-in automatic differentiation
so we have a typical workflow of using
numpy code is we have some
code using numpy
um
and we put an array into that code and
we get out usually another numpy array
well i can take that exact same code
whether you wrote it or i wrote it or it
was provided to us by scikit-learn
and i can instead pass a migraine tensor
into it
that's what i mean by drop-in and what
will come out is another is a migraine
tensor
but that my grad tensor will know how to
take the derivative of the code that we
were using again whether or not you had
written the code or i did or if it was
some functionality provided by
scikit-learn or some other numpy based
library
so how does it do this well
the mygrads tensor has two functions
that implement a protocol that's
actually provided by numpy itself that
allows you to override numpy's ufunks or
functions
so when i call numpy dot einstein on a
migraine tensor numpy actually sees that
i have this function override and i'm
saying hey numpy i actually have my own
version of einstem that i want to use
please use that instead but the end user
doesn't know it the end user just calls
numpy's version of it on on the tensor
doesn't jax do this already
well
jax doesn't provide drop in automatic
differentiation it provides swap out
automatic differentiation
so
in order to use jax's numpy code to add
autodiff you need to write your numpy
code using jax's numpy not using vanilla
numpy so if someone else some
third-party library already wrote their
code with numpy you can't go and swap
out
their numpai with jax's numpai
so you can't simply put drop a jax array
into third-party numpy code is what i'm
saying and also jax has limited
limited support for numpy you can't do
in-place operations for example
is my grad
okay you might be asking yourself is my
great bad like is this actually good is
this just gonna be some dude's little
baby repo and he implemented derivatives
for multiply and add and cosine
no it's pretty good i've been working on
this for four years it's been
too much you should take a look at the
source code sometime it's a bit much uh
it's lightweight it's only dependency is
numpy so if you already have numpy
installed you do pip install my grad all
you're going to get is my grad
it supports broadcasting
in place operations memory sharing views
with
parity among uh the actual gradients so
the gradients share memory as well
first class supports free support for
you funcs so you can use wear masks out
targets to write to specific parts of
tensors
gosh darn robust support for einstein
which is just like the killer linear
algebra operation you can even do views
of diagonals
that took me an entire weekend
it's fully type annotated
super duper tested using hypothesis
library i became a developer on the
hypothesis testing library because of my
work on my grad
and it has pretty solid docs i like we
have examples for all of our code and
stuff like that
um and we even have some neural network
operations you can make you can do
n-dimensional convolutions pooling
layers batch norms we even have a group
um so it's it's a pretty serious library
you might also ask i already use jax
should i use my grad instead oh my
goodness no absolutely not
my grad is not meant to compete with jax
my grab does not have higher order
derivatives
jet capabilities parallelization
any funding
a large user base
or a team of super smart super competent
paid developers from like google brain
no we do not have those things uh
so
why should num the num focus community
care about my brand then um first of all
it's super accessible it's maybe the
easiest way to compute derivatives
within the numpy ecosystem um it's just
numpy but then you call that backward
at the end of it and you get the
derivatives it's awesome for teaching i
teach an outreach course through mit to
high school students about machine
learning and all we use is mygrad it
doesn't have the sharp edges of trying
to install pie torch across different
operating systems or dealing with
i mean jacks can't even be installed on
windows without hacks um the
documentation is more user friendly and
if students want to know how to use
mygrad i just tell them or i just teach
them how to use numpy which will teach
them how to use pandas how to use x-ray
how to use coupon right numpy is at the
core of this entire ecosystem so just
learn how to use that
it could
add auto diff to coupe i x-ray das
sparse array there's this emerging array
api standard that ralph dahmer's is
spearheading and
i designed my grad really carefully to
have parody with numpy so you could use
a migraine tensor under the hood to add
auto different fit auto diff to these
other really popular and really powerful
libraries
and the last reason is i don't really
plan to work on this anymore unless
people find the above useful and i don't
mean that in like a negative way and i
don't mean i don't want your pity i'm
just saying i'm happy with my grad as is
it's really great for my personal use
cases in teaching but
if people look at the above and say hey
i really want auto diff for sparse array
then please reach out to me i would love
to have people extend this project and
continue working on it but just in terms
of like me by myself with no one other
than my students using it
i'm happy with it it is what it is uh
finally it's not my grad it's our grad i
always have to explain this to my
students i didn't name it being like
it's my ryan subclass use grad it's
supposed to be
relative to the actual user um yeah and
so my grad is on github on pipe pipey
you can find me at rsokl on github and
twitter and i'm giving another talk at
five o'clock so if you like my energy
and if you like the style of this talk
please come learn about hydrazine which
is a pretty serious library that i'm
that i'm working on
thanks everyone
thanks ryan
awesome uh
so they did
can you maybe type in the chat how
people can uh find you on on github
yep r-s-o-k-l for github and twitter
thanks a lot uh with that we can move to
the
talk with the shuen too and uh excuse me
if i didn't pronounce it well
uh
do we have you here yeah all right i'm
here
okay fantastic you can share the
presentation and okay let me show my
screen
um
and i can go and get to
coming so small
okay now it's full screen
hello everyone my name is showan tu i'm
here
to talk about a very simple exercise
approximating pi with fractions
using python
so here's the outline of my talk in the
interest of time i'll just
skip through
so here's the motivation pi is a really
interesting
number and apparently there is a
competition
worldwide and throughout history to
to see who completes the most the number
of digits
right so this graph was a
computed
was generated back in 2012
on wikipedia uploaded there and then i
added three later
events just in the past say two and a
half years
so seeing those interests i i was also
learning
python okay still learning
so i asked myself what are good
fractional approximations of pi
and what are python features that are
useful say if i investigated this
and i'm not going to hold it
to the end so here are the answers i
found
basically the ratio 355 data by did by
113
is a very good approximation with 85 pvp
and also quite memorable and the next is
a 22x7 with a 402 ppm accuracy it's also
quite um familiar i think to many people
and in the
course of the learning i found the
decimal
and the fraction and even inked to be
very useful
so first i loaded the decimal
module and the fractions module
both are in built-in modules then i
immediately set the precision to 52
decimal points in the context
then i found a
the 50 the first 50 digits of pi from
this pi page sorry from this wikipedia
page and i passed that to the decimal
constructor
and i was happy to see that it appeared
to retain all the
50 digits
to start with i look at the math.pi and
numpy.pi they are equal and their
accuracy is roughly 4 e minus 17.
and
and this 50 digits of pi is roughly
three times of that
so here is the main part of this it
really is a as simple so this talk is
more like a joke to any of the jokes you
hear so far
i passed the
decimal pi with 50 digits to fraction
and i use the method limit denominator
to ask for
fraction approximations to this
decimal number
right and i
i pass in this max denomination
denominator
with larger and larger numbers and then
i calculated the error
and i need to use the decimal
representation of these numbers to get
the relative error and then collect the
denominator and error and print out the
results here so what we see is that as
the
max denominator is allowed to double
going down right the both the
denominator and the numerator of the
fraction approximation indeed get much
bigger and the relative error
also became much smaller so here is the
rest of the printout
as the max denominator go gets close to
two to the power of 90 we maxed out the
precision in there i mean the 50 digits
of the pi and also the 52 digits of
precision i said in a context
so here is a plot of the relative error
against the limit denominator both in
log scale and i need to multiply those
with the negative
relative error with a decimal minus one
to have them show up in the log scale
and one thing we see is that a few
fractional
approximations
um they are good over a range of
limit denominators meaning they are good
right so i pointed out the four
obvious ones here and
to my head only the first two are
memorable
and by the way this ratio of a three
five five divided by 113
so it was known historically as just
ratio it was discovered by a
mathematician in 5th century in china so
it was a
interesting one in there
there is also the so-called continued
fraction representation of pi so this
formula is taken from wikipedia what we
see is that
it has a very regular structure and
these series of numbers essentially
together with the structure essentially
defines this
continued fraction
right
so the the wikipedia page says
truncating it should give us these
numbers
so i did this manually with the four
first four terms to confirm that i knew
how to do it
then
then i wrote a small recursive function
to calculate that so i found these first
two 20 terms from this webpage
and then
after correcting this function it worked
out these terms and indeed the
22 over 7 and the 355 over 113 are here
and the first a couple of term a dozen
of terms
already
matched what's listed in that wikipedia
page as well
so here is one way of looking at why is
this ratio so good so in this simple
continued fraction
representation this number 292 is quite
large
meaning that dropping this
only creates a small error in the result
and indeed
this ratio can be obtained by retaining
only the first few terms and dropping
order
292 and the beyond
so here's the takeaway of my talk it's a
very simple one
the
a very good a fraction approximation is
this ratio 355 divided by 113 and one
trick to memorize this
is uh the inverse of that is one one
three three five five with the divide
sign right in the middle but it has
impressive accuracy so the runner up is
our more familiar 22 divided by 7 with
402 ppm and in the course of working out
this exercise i learned about decimal
correction and even inked with the
number not maxing out at
say in 64 limit i was also
happily delighted
finally here is a
github link
okay thank you
thanks a lot shun uh
and we can now move to the
talk afterwards
with
osman with the need to
or for modular data science solutions do
we have osmond
yes
hello can you hear me okay
yeah i can hear you
right so as you you're setting up your
presentation can you uh show and can you
stop sharing your screen
um
how do i do that
um
can you take the
control away or stop sharing i found it
sorry okay okay great
okay i'm just gonna go ahead and share
my screen
all right in the meantime
i'll try to throw up on uh
there are two kinds of data scientists
like first ones uh the ones who can
interpolate or extrapolate from and
complete data
and now you can start your your talk
that's fun
um so hi everyone my name is osman
cameron and i'll be talking to you about
the need for modular data science
solutions
um
and let's get this rolling
so i'm part of uh now vertical group
it's an
it's a group that focuses on delivering
data science solutions to a number of
industries and use cases and it's the
parent company of a company that i've
been involved in in the past three years
or so
called integra and integra really
focuses on
delivering
data-driven applications and data-driven
insights to use cases within the oil and
gas industry
my role within this sphere is as the
cloud solutions architect and the
technical lead of the digital hub
project digital hub is a cloud data
scalable
um
data science platform that is ready to
be used i encourage everyone to take a
look into it this talk is really
focusing on some of the things i've
learned over the last three or four
years while i've been transforming data
science experiments into data science
projects and then ultimately data-driven
applications for enterprise
um use cases
and some of what i've learned
is the importance of modularity within
this entire sphere so
um
a lot of the time what happens when it
comes to data science experiments and
data science teams is that they exist
within their own independent silo where
the goal is just value generation from
the
data that's available to you and a lot
of the times it makes sense because
um
most
most often when
data is provided for data science teams
um it's unclear as to whether they will
be able to
generate insight from it or not there's
a lot of time that goes into data
processing and data cleaning and
before having a good idea of what the
data contains what the data entails
it's difficult to identify whether or
not you'll be able to generate value
but in
restricting data scientists to their own
independent silo what ends up happening
is
long messy jupiter notebooks that while
ultimately functional um are not product
ready at all um and the goal um when it
comes to the scope being an enterprise
really an enterprise-related application
is really to have product-ready code
or code that can be easily parlayed into
a back-end api or back-end of an
application
once this process is complete
so in order to bridge that gap it's
important for development teams that
play a role in the data science
experimentation phase just so you can
have
and maintain
consistent standards when it comes to
formatting code and showing that the
code that you have can be parlayed into
a backend ready application
and oftentimes this take this this saves
months and months of time when it comes
to reworking code into
um
into a into the back end of an
enterprise grade application
um so even with an evolving scope
the application comes comes along with
you
and i guess when it comes to breaking
things down into its own position
components that's really where
modularization comes in because the key
goal of modularization is to
break everything down into constituent
components that can be reused and
that can scale independently so
uh the smallest most four components i'm
sure we're all
that we're all familiar with fire
functions
functions are your friends use them
often use them well and document them as
much as possible
because these functions can be it might
seem trivial but these functions can be
easily paralleled into
any given application regardless of the
use case itself they're the smallest
constituent component of um
an application that can be easily
transferable
so functions are your friends use them
often the second thing is parallelism
and concurrency we're well past the days
of single core engines and single
threading and it's important for
data scientists and developers both to
be cognizant of this and really
utilize the compute available to you um
in the multi-core world that we live in
so you can have
if you can have tasks being interleaved
into multiple course multiple processes
you should do so
and the way to do so is
by using spark
spark has
a wide variety of use cases
specifically for mapreduce functions
desk is another library that exists or
even python's own uh native
multi-processing library
um
[Music]
what this also allows for is later on
once you're utilizing compute at a much
larger scale in
an enterprise-ready application
you can utilize
a far greater amount of compute
available to you and also makes data
processing a lot more
efficient as well
the last thing is think about
infrastructure early so there are a
number of different
benefits of doing so when you think
about the infrastructure early you can
as a data scientist you can
if you can containerize your code and
have it ready to deploy on the scalable
infrastructure you already have an idea
of
the financial overhead required to run
your application if it's going to be
translated into
an application of any sort and this can
help inform the financial stakeholders
at play as to what will be required when
it comes to this level of transformation
which is key in
decision making
and
the business value that this
piece of work can ultimately generate
so there's a financial component of it
the second is
the
value that a data scientist can
deliver
from testing their code on an increasing
amount of data
with the scalable infrastructure so
dockerizing containerizing your code and
having that modular component
at play
it gives you the ability to test with an
increasing
data set and
[Music]
further test your ideas um
yeah so that those are my little keys to
success when it comes to transform
transformation of data science solution
and i hope you found this helpful
thank you
thank you very much osman uh
i can
at least for uh the lessons that you
shared at least relate to
that half of my time spent cleaning the
data and the other half is complaining
about
cleaning
[Music]
uh with that we can move to the next uh
presentation with
ardo
do we have ado here
and osman
you can now
start sharing your screen
uh what about
g oh ardu are you here yep i'm here all
right okay
all right uh you can go ahead
all right thank you um
just getting started here all right um
excited to be here
appreciate everybody who's turned up on
a saturday um
i'm ardo and i'm a data scientist at
clio
and we are a
software as a service company
operating in the legal tech field
and i'm going to give you a little bit
of information about how to use survival
analysis to
study customer behavior
so
if you go and google survival analysis
what you usually
most likely end up is like figures like
this from clinical trials or medical
papers
and it's a fair question to us like what
we do with survival analysis in a
software company and it turns out like
we can do quite a bit so
i'll cover two examples the first would
be churn so churn is when we
lose our existing paying customers so we
lose revenue and obviously that's that's
not something the company wants to see
so it's definitely something you want to
keep an eye on and how those numbers and
metrics
are
and the standard approach is pretty
straightforward you you look at how many
accounts you have at the start of some
time period usually like a month or so
and then you look at the end of the time
period and how many accounts you lost
and the churn rate is just the ratio of
those
um this is fine uh
if you want to just kind of have a
really sort of overall view
but
sometimes we want to kind of zoom in a
little bit more so that for example
let's say we have we have a hunch that
our there's something wrong with our
onboarding process and we're losing a
lot of customers like in the early stage
of their customer journey
so we want to like really understand
like what's happening in like the first
30 days after the customer signs up
um and to kind of
get a little bit more quantitative about
this i'm going to generate a data set
for one month so for each day in a month
we'll have
a thousand year accounts that sign up
and then each of those accounts after
they have signed up have a two percent
probability of churning on any day so
it's not dependent on
how long they have been a client is two
percent flat every day
so
if we can we can visualize this data and
and
like we have time going from
left to right here and each of these
lines represents uh one account or one
customer
um and this is like the data we would
usually have like if we just pull data
from our database this is what we don't
know anything about
you know how we generated it
um
and here like the the left side of the
line shows when the customer signs up
and for the red lines the end of the
line shows where they turned
uh for the blue lines they just well
they didn't churn in this time period
that we're looking at so we just know
that well there are still our customers
at the end
of this
the time period we're looking
um so if we now use the sort of simple
approach uh and calculate okay out of
all the new accounts in august or well
august is the month that we were
simulating here out of all the accounts
all the new accounts in august how many
children we get 26
um but this turns out not to be really
what we were looking we were interested
in like the overall behavior of like new
accounts within 30 days
and and this doesn't give us that
because like some of the accounts
uh that signed up at the start of the
month they would have had 30 days to
churn and those accounts signed up at
the end would have had just a few days
so the sort of cumulative risk these
accounts are exposed to
um is is different and we're kind of
mixing and matching this kind of apples
and oranges here um
and to kind of compare these at an equal
footing i'll actually start we should
use something called time event analysis
uh sorry time to event analysis or also
known as survival analysis
and
what this means that instead of just
focusing on whether the end event
occurred in this case whether the
customer churn
we instead look at the durations from
start event to the end event but we also
include the cases where
the event did not occur
but it just kind of went beyond our kind
of horizon where we're looking at so
this kind of stuff is called censoring
and we see it also in this example data
set we have so all the blue lines
are effectively censored because
all we know about them is that they
didn't churn before the
end of our time period we don't know
what happens afterwards but we should
include them in our analysis as long as
we have data
so we convert this data to the sort of
duration
uh
count and
and we we know the duration for each
account we know whether they churned or
not
and we know whether they were censored
or not so using just these three pieces
of information now we can apply survival
analysis and the kind of classical
approach here is to use capital my
estimator
and if you can plug these numbers in
there and
and crunch them a bit you'll get this
sort of
nice curve out which tells you the
probability of an account churning
by
the given number of days so we were
interested in the first month of account
activity so in this case we would look
at the 30 day
uh
the third year value of this of this
curve so we get around 46
percent here if you compare that what we
got with the naive approach it's
considerably higher so we would be
really underestimating our churn if we
just rely on the first approach
um okay so we've established that we
have a problem with early children
there's a 46 percent chance that it
counted churns within the first 30 days
so we should do something about it let's
say we have some magical solution ready
off the shelf we plug it in and like the
next month
uh all the accounts are now going
through a different onboarding process
and we you know wait for a month and see
what happens so
after we do the calculations again to
the capital meyer estimator um we see
that now the orange line is the second
second month so it's considerably lower
and it kind of shows that okay our
mitigation efforts are paid off
um
another useful thing that we get from
survival analysis is the so-called
hazard function and in this case it's
equivalent to showing us like what is
the risk of churning on a given day
and if you remember in the beginning we
said that that's two percent probability
of churning every day and and we're able
to extract that from from this data
using survival analysis and we also see
that uh for the second month when we
deployed our fix uh we we saw that uh
the risk of churning had dropped to one
percent so we kind of stopped pretty
neat to get out of this
this analysis
um
the second type of thing i want to look
at is uh
something called product activation so
that's when
we have a new account signing up and
we're interested in when they
start using a certain feature in our
product for example like if you sign up
to youtube how long does it take for you
to start uploading your first video
um so it's similar but there's an added
complication here because
uh it's also possible that the account
churns before it even gets the event so
that's something we would have to take
into account in our analysis
um and again to kind of quantify this a
bit more i'm going to do a generated
data set again thousand-year accounts
the same turn probabilities two percent
at first and one percent later but then
throughout the two periods like two
months we'll have a flat five percent
probability of
the account using this product feature
we're interested in order also known as
activity
and what we want to understand is can we
estimate activation probability even
when all of these churn changes are
going on
so if we just use the first approach
uh just like you know start event end
event
we'll actually end up with something
that we are not expecting like
we are like which which would mislead us
if we didn't know that the
activation rate is constant over time in
this case we would see that well the
september activation rate is higher than
august it's kind of depending on the
turn rate then and also on the right we
see that the
the activation probability seems to be
going down over time
which also we didn't specify we had a
flat flat activation rate overall
um so if and the problem this problem
occurs because we're not taking churn
into account here we're just ignoring
the
the effect of churn on this
but if we do take journal into account
in our calculations we we actually are
able to obtain the results that we would
like to see we have the activation
probability for both ones is the same
regardless of the term behavior and
we're also able to retrieve the
the activation probability the flat ones
it's getting a bit more there's more
variance at the end there because
there's fewer days at the end
but um otherwise it's it's flat around
five percent
and uh yeah that's those are the two
examples i wanted to cover quickly um
it shows pretty nicely how you can
employ survival analysis using and to
analyze customer data
and this was done using the lifelines
library it's uh open source or python
and you can do a lot more fancy things
with it like regression models to figure
out which features contribute to
survival and how they do that
and a bunch of other stuff and it has
really good documentation very nice
tutorials so really recommend you
checking it out
and uh yeah
coincidentally yesterday there was a
workshop done in pi data which was about
competition computational survival
analysis so if you want to kind of know
what's
um kind of under the hood of all this
feel free to check out the recording
it's it was it's pretty neat
and that's that's all i have so uh if
anybody has any questions or uh like
follow-ups feel free to reach out to me
either email or linkedin
and uh yeah thank you for attention and
enjoy the rest of the
session
thank you very much outdoor and it's
actually very useful for me personally
for my own use case so thank you for for
the talk
i i think we have the last talk for uh
our lightning sessions
with jason do we have jason
all right
all right uh whenever you're ready jason
you can start
all right um yeah thanks um
thanks for uh coming to the talk for the
topic uh title is improving topic model
interpretability through aggregation
jason lee
by way of a quick introduction i'm a
staff software engineer at flatiron
health project is independent of any
work at flatiron and it's a independent
project been doing over the last three
or so years uh in conjunction with the
university of cincinnati digital library
and just a quick plug
flatiron is hiring software engineers
and data scientists i posted on the job
board so please reach out
if you have any interest or questions
around that
um all right so the
topic modeling primer uh banjo actually
talked a little bit about this earlier
but i'll just
give a little bit more summary on topic
modeling it's a unsupervised learning
method to find topic clusters in a
document corpus
so for example the algorithm will learn
term topic topic document weights
allowing the certain late relationships
based on the co-occurrence of those
terms across documents
to rise up
there are a lot of use cases in industry
but there are also certain drawbacks to
the algorithm
sensitive to initial conditions
leading to topics not always being
interpretable or reproducible and this
is sort of uh well described
below in the blow quote there's a
fundamental instability in these
algorithms and different runs the same
algorithm can produce different outcomes
so then what did we do to
uh yeah
try to make this better well our
approach was to aggregate topic models
so then for a given set of input
documents for certain corpus aggregate
uh recurring topics across runs so what
we did is
run many
pi spark lda models say around 50 per
experiment with different topic counts
ranging from 50 to 400
that allowed consistent topics to bubble
to the top and it was a more natural way
to get the number of topics and clusters
generally the number of topics is a
parameter you need to input at the start
for when generating the model lda model
and it allowed us to smooth out the
terms
uh like
reduce some of the the variability from
the random initial initialization of the
models um and the clusters were formed
by aggregating topics using kensington
shannon pairwise distance and some
network-based uh clustering heuristics
uh so just to
dive into uh an example here so
this uh is from
a pubmed search
for machine learning and artificial
intelligence there are about 30 000
documents there
and you see two example topics which
group
which are grouped into the aggregated
healthcare innovation ethical cluster
but uh looking at the topic on the left
uh it's not immediately apparent that it
is pertinent to healthcare uh there's
nothing related to healthcare health in
the top 10 terms here
but it's only when compared
as the topic is a distribution with
other topic runs across different models
that it's clear that it's part of this
latent theme of uh healthcare innovation
and like ethics around machine learning
um
and
yeah so as i mentioned yeah we this is
for the uh the machine learning ai docs
in pubmed but then the we also color uh
created a ui to sort of um to understand
the
the
model and the color coded by confidence
and what we call ubiquity across the
models for example 90 of the models have
uh the similar topic or 75 percent et
cetera
um but then
but then how do we evaluate uh the the
models how can we say that they are more
uh interpretable well we use coherence
which is a standard way to standard
proxy for human interpretability
and in the table on the right uh show
the
on the top uh the mlai uh documents from
pubmed
and individual spark lda runs
where we are comparing so sort of the 50
topic models we ran 20 20 models for
those
and the mean coherence across those was
0.493 493 the 200 topic models ran 12 uh
12 rounds of those and mean coherence
was
0.499 but then the aggregated model if
you focus first on the part bolded in
black
uh the aggregated model had a
mean coherent a coherence of 0.596 and
that yielded 115 uh topics or clusters
uh
um
but then the folded in red is for the
the models the bullet and black are the
ones where it appeared in greater than
ten percent of the models uh but then
the bolded in red is where it created
greater than 25 of the models and that
uh coherence uh at 0.657 so higher
confidence um
a higher coherence on that and but then
the trade-off was there is a a lower
number of uh
clusters or topics uh in this case 61 uh
that um
or in a hat greater than 25 greater than
25 of the models we ran similar
experiments for pubmed documents which
were published in q4 of 2020. there are
400 000 documents there and you can see
likewise uh uh improved uh coherence uh
with the aggregated model versus the the
individual lda topic models just one
point is for the mlai uh model we
generated 3600 topics across all the lda
runs and about 1 000 of those were used
in the final aggregated model i mean i
guess the intuition here and
we need to
dig into this a bit more is that 70
percent of the topics are noisy or
inconsistent
then to the next slide
so yeah for in order to generate the
these aggregated models we need a lot of
raw material a lot of these uh topics uh
we initially tried gensim even with the
distributed or multi-processed virgin
agent sim and that was still uh took a
little a bit of time but the pi spark
implementation of lda was very fast even
on a relatively small cluster of two to
three r5 8x large machines on aws were
able to run for the 30 000 document
corpus within
a 50 topic model within a few minutes uh
400 topic model within 10 minutes so we
had all the 50 topic um
lda runs that we needed within a few
hours for the larger 400 000 document
corpus we were able to do it for 24
minutes to an hour depending on the
number of topics and we had all the raw
uh topic models we needed within a
couple of days
uh and just to sort of illustrate the
overall pipeline uh the documents were
uh ingested into elasticsearch and we
did some pre-processing using sci-spacey
and then using pi spark uh generated the
models and computed the pairwise
distances between the topics and then
post that we use network x to build a
model uh fill a graph of the topics
and sk learned to refine these clusters
using db scan and finally chance them to
score the models uh the coherence scores
for the models and we did a quick search
phase uh to determine the best uh
parameters uh for the uh final
aggregated model cluster
and
um yeah the work we
just yielded a paper on the core 19 data
set that was published in the uh harvard
data science review in conjunction with
the university of cincinnati digital
library one takeaway was there was a 71
correspond 71 correspondence human
annotated labels and you can see how
this could potentially
streamline expedite human annotation
using some of these high confidence
clusters
and a link to the model is uh provided
below which you'll share in the slides
and yeah thank you for listening
thanks a lot jason and congratulations
on publishing the paper are you gonna
post uh
like for people what can they find the
link to
uh i can post the slides in uh
in slack yes okay
uh with that uh we conclude our
lightning talks for today thank you
everyone for joining us
uh and i hope everyone enjoyed the talks
you can find the recordings on the
website we have recorded all all the
talks you could revisit or approach the
the people that give the talks and with
that thank you so much and have a great
evening
all right